Um, well, I think we should start
the story on June 25th, 1969. Well,
first you should say who you are. I'm
Susie Lichtenberg. I'm Janet. I'm Rod.
This is more perfect. Okay. So
why, uh, why June 20? When was it?
June 25th, 1969, uh,
Supreme Court Chief Justice
Earl Warren is retiring.
Earl Warren of the Warren Court. Is
that a big court? Yeah, that's really,
no, come on human re, I think if you
think of legendary Supreme Court justices,
he's probably in, I
don't know, the top five.
So he was one of the Mount Olympians.
He's a big deal. All right,
so he's retiring. So he's retiring.
He's been on the court for 16 years and
he's in an interview and he's asked,
what'd you list Mr Chief Justice as the
supreme court's most important decision
in your 16 years here? And he says
something that is kind of astounding.
I think the reapportionment
not only of state legislatures,
but for sure
before you hear the answer. Yeah.
I think that you need to know that he
could have said all kinds of cases.
He was the chief justice
during, I don't know, Miranda,
either of his rights to
remain silent. That's,
you have the right to remain silent.
Clarence Earl Gideon petition
or Gideon versus Wainwright.
It is the beauty of the space,
which is you have the right to an attorney
that seems big or has no place in our
democracy. Brown vs
board of Education. Okay.
I know that one. I know
desegregating the schools of state.
It could be bigger than that. He doesn't
say any of those. What does he say?
He says this little
case called [inaudible]
the baker versus Carr case.
Baker versus Carr. Huh.
I think that uh,
that that case is perhaps
the most important case that
we've had since I've been
on the court.
He thought that case, whatever it is,
is more important than the case that
desegregated the schools. He did. Wow.
So what the hell is it
exactly? No, really what is it?
It's this case that was so dramatic and
so traumatic that it apparently broke
two justices.
There was an instance in which my brother
found my father going upstairs to get
a shotgun. Wow. More perfect.
The auto,
all the chief justice and the associate
justices of the Supreme Court of the
United States. All Da da.
Yeah. But before the
[inaudible] the draw in Aaron
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Okay. So this is more of perfect
a mini series about the supreme
court. Just to frame the story
we're about to hear for a second.
As we were putting the show together, um,
we hosted a panel discussion and a couple
of us were on stage and a woman in the
audience asked the following
question. Yes. Could you, um,
address what I see is the increasing
politicization of the court,
the apotheosis of which I
guess was, uh, you know,
voting or electing Bush
to be our president.
Has the court always been this way?
Is this just my perception that
it's becoming more politicized?
So this turns out to be really
interesting question. Uh, it turns out,
I didn't know this until Susie started
looking into it, that there was a moment
when the Pandora's box
just got ripped open.
So I think to understand
that moment in this story,
you have to get to know three characters.
And these aren't necessarily the three
most important justices of all time.
Okay.
Because at that time you had Chief Justice
Earl Warren [inaudible] and William
Brennan on the court. And these were
kind of giants of the Supreme Court.
Gotcha. But for this story,
these three guys are key.
One of them is on the right.
One of them is on the left and one of
them is just stuck right in the middle,
tragically in the middle.
So on the conservative side.
So Ryan,
what difference does it make when it
in the constitution or in any other
expression or action by the state?
You had a guy named Felix Frankfurter.
So Justice Frankfurter was one of the
most great is really his name was really
framed further. Yes. One of the most
influential justices of all time. I,
that's Tara Grove.
She teaches constitutional law at
William and Mary Law School. Um,
he was a very influential scholar at
Harvard law school before he became a
justice, was a close advisor to
Franklin Delano Roosevelt. Um,
he was extremely smart, towering figure.
But as a person just as
just justice frankfurter,
he wasn't necessarily the nicest person.
I heard that from everyone I talk to.
I always call him a Bantam Rooster.
Uh, he was a difficult crusty figure.
He was short, a little
bit of a pouch on him.
It was one of the most condescending
egotistical of justices.
He was a tough customer when a,
when a clerk would come to the u s supreme
court chambers to deliver a message,
and the person at the door tried to
hand justice frankfurter the paper,
Frankfurt or would inevitably
let it drop to the ground.
So the person had to bend down and pick
it up to hand it to him again. Dude,
that's a Wainer man. And by the way,
the voices you heard besides terra
grove are professors. Mike Seidman,
Georgetown University Law Center, because
Sam is that girl from NYU law school.
Craig Smith, California, University of
Pennsylvania and x Supreme Court clerk.
Alan Cohen, column K La Chan. Okay.
So Frankfurter is on one side of the aisle
and his nemesis is a gentleman on the
other side of the island,
a liberal named William O. Douglas
here is Justice
Douglas now and the Supreme
Court chambers. He said yes,
this is a recording from a 1957
interview with Justice Douglas.
It looks very well as
the faceless 10 rugged,
his eyes sparkle Douglas was this
mountain climbing environmentalist big on
civil liberties.
I think that the coming generation is
more aware of the importance of civil
liberties and perhaps like generation low
and like Justice Frankfurter
Douglas was a prick
to everybody around him. Everybody
hated him. All those same adjectives,
condescending, egotistical,
abrasive, applied.
Here's how the New York
Times described him.
Oh, habitual. A womanizer, a heavy
drinker, and uncaring parents.
Douglas was married four times cheating
on each of his first three wives with
her eventual successor. Do you believe
in kissing your bride, sir? Oh,
sure. Do you mind,
this is footage from his last
marriage to his wife Kathleen.
He was 67 she was 22
Oh yes.
So yes, yes. That is. That is William
Douglas. So you have these two guys,
Frankfurt or the Bantam Rooster. Douglas
the prick. And as you can imagine,
they hated each other. They
just despised each other.
So Frankfurter had this
habit of monologuing and
while he would go on and on,
Douglas would just pull out a book right
in front of him and just start reading.
You know, he was just open and
his disdain for Frankfurter.
I actually found a series of interviews
that were done with Douglas in the early
sixties, where he basically
calls frankfurter names.
No, see evil, utterly dishonest.
Intellectually. He was
very great, devious.
He spent his time going
up and down the holes,
putting the poisons in everybody's sprawl.
Wow. Why did they hate each other so
much? Well, according to Mike Seidman,
some of that comes from maybe
their difference in background.
Frank footer was a Jewish
immigrant from Austria.
A Douglas was a westerner,
but according to him, the core of
their hatred actually was ideological,
had reflected, um, a
really important split
over how powerful the court should
be. Though for frank footer,
courts just ought not to intervene.
He believed that in many matters should
be left up to the political process and
the courts should stay
out of those issues.
It's Douglas. Um, he
thought just the opposite.
He thought that courts want to
intervene to protect, for example,
minority groups, free speech
rights, things of that sort.
So you had this personal feud going.
You had this ideological war that was
brewing in the court and into the middle
of all this
[inaudible]
Lux, Charles, whatever you
might call them, the swing vote.
Okay. This is Alan Colton.
I was a supreme court clerk.
Justice Whitaker from 1957 to 1958
Whitaker grew up in a small town in Kansas
called Troy. The activist is a flashy,
this is his granddaughter kicked you
tend to kind of a one room school house.
Verby a little red school house.
Worked on the farm, but he,
he, he determined that
was not the life for him.
Kate says when he was around 16 he became
obsessed with the idea of becoming a
lawyer and she says he would
actually practice law to the animals.
Can you imagine, you know,
pushing the plow along in the fields and
then lecturing and arguing cases to the
cows or to the horses or whatever.
Did you really hear that
he was lecturing dude? Yes.
Oh and on the side he was, he would
hunt, he would hunt a squirrels, possum,
raccoons, dunks,
and he'd sell the pelts for a few dollars
and he amassed I think $700 with that
money you put himself through law school.
My understanding is that he simultaneously
went to law school and high school
what, which is just
mind boggling, but yeah,
apparently he went to the head of the
law school in Kansas City and he's like,
I don't have a high school
diploma, but you need to let me in.
The Dean just saw how ambitious he was
and he was impressed and he's like,
all right, you're in. I love this
guy. He's like, Mr bootstraps.
Totally any how to make
a long story short,
sone became a top lawyer and Alan Cohen
says that's because he would do better
than all of his opponents. He would
outwork them out, prepare them,
great attention to detail,
great presence before a jury and
then he becomes a judge. First,
a federal district judge and
then an appeals court judge.
Then in February of 1957 he gets the call.
Carla was in the evening and they asked
if he could be in Washington. Yeah,
and the next morning, and this is
Kentwood a group, Charles Whitaker's son.
He should certainly, but my best blue
shoot deals at the cleaners tonight.
What did he wear? I, as a matter of fact,
my mother or someone else got
the cleaners to open up at night
in the first stern must be allegation
tending to show that the corporation's
right dog exercise of free
will let them destroy.
This is one of the first times that
Whitaker spoke on the bench and he
interjects with a question for the
attorney and he is the Midwestern plate.
Yes. I guess the,
you've had so many interruptions
but I have a question or two.
I wonder if I might have the
privilege of asking sir. I think
the thing that's crazy to me is that
he walked into the highest court in the
land and he didn't even go to college.
I think it's important to understand
that he had no formal education really.
In other words,
he never took history or political
science or social science,
but he loved the law. My
father was not an ideal law.
He expected the court to be an arena
in which there were lively arguments on
legal issues and that's
what he enjoyed. What he,
what's really good at
what he loved as Kent Whittaker puts it.
His Dad was kind of the walking embodiment
of that thing that chief justice John
Roberts said back in 2005 during his
confirmation hearing your chairman,
I come before the committee with no
agenda. He was sort of a blank slate.
It's my job to call balls and
strikes and not to pitch or bat.
My father was not interested
in advancing a cause or a fury,
but frankly that seems
how a justice should be.
That you are approaching it without a
political agenda and you're deciding it.
In theory. That's exactly
right, but in practice,
so many of their cases,
there is no wall to turn
to to decide those cases.
Ken says that his dad
quickly discovered that law,
the Supreme Court is never
clean. Cut cases make it there.
Precisely because the law isn't clear.
Many of their cases are just without
precedent, and it's in those cases,
at least you have must have.
Your ideology is a as a starting point,
and the fact that he didn't have an
ideology that left him vulnerable,
he was definitely getting lobbied from
both sides, Frankfurt or on one side,
Douglas on the other.
You were the new kid on the block
and was being pulled by each one.
He didn't like the way the judges
bullied for votes within his first three
months. He found himself in the
middle of a death penalty case.
She was found in her bedroom by firemen
taken outside and soon thereafter
pronounced that
a guy had been tried for arson and murder
and Douglas and the liberals wanted to
intervene to help them.
They felt like he'd been treated
unfairly by the lower courts,
but frankfurter in the Conservatives
thought that the supreme court should be
cautious. They should honor precedent.
Now, according to Justice Douglas,
justice Whittaker was undecided all the
time. Douglas would tell him one thing,
oh, well, yeah, that seems right.
And then just as frank herder would say
something else and you say, oh gosh,
that sounds right.
I think there was some thought that he
might side with the guy who talked with
him last, you know,
he ends up being so undecided on this
death penalty case that he forces the
court to delay the vote until the next
term and there were a series of cases
like [inaudible],
this Halbert ill tro,
where the law would be fuzzy
ideologies would harden and Whitaker.
He would be right in the middle of the
physical depictions of him in that first
year from people who saw him,
described somebody who was
restless, terribly unhappy.
I had lost a lot of weight. Nervous
was agitated most of the time.
It was a lot of stress on him.
I mean, I took,
this was just quicker that in normal
course on the California procedure,
the medical, yeah.
Great. Perfect. Over the next few years,
he bounces back. He finds his feet.
Yeah.
You say that the judgment
on probation, his
production increased substantially in
his third year, his fourth year
and part of his fifth year.
He wrote as many opinions
as any other judge.
He wrote as many dissenting opinions as
any other judge. He was one of the nine.
He was fully implied and he wrote some
very important opinions during that
period of time and along came a
baker versus Carr and it broke them.
[inaudible] it's coming up.
Hi, this is Shereen from sunrise, Florida.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
this is Kenneth Polaski
from Plymouth, Michigan.
Radiolab is supported by TBS is new
original comedy search party on TBS and
official selection at the 2016
south by southwest film festival.
Watch the mystery unravel as a lost soul
and her group of friends search for a
missing girl they barely even knew you
can binge the entire season of search
party in one week, starting Monday,
November the 21st at 1110 central on TBS.
Hi, this is Mckenna Anderson at
the University of South Florida.
Currently in the woman's laboratory.
Radiolab is supported by Poopourri
the before you go toilet spray.
The good folks at Poopourri once reminded
that using the restroom for 10 minutes
each day at work equals
40 hours a year. Hey,
that's like an extra week of vacation.
So is it [inaudible] dot com to find out
how you can go anywhere with confidence
even at work into the discount code.
Where do you a lab for
20% off@potpourri.com
see ya.
Hey, this is more perfect.
I'm jet apple. I'm Rod.
Let's get back to our story from Susie
Lichtenberg about the case that broke two
justices.
[inaudible] number 180 Trey
Charles w your banker at out,
but tell him a balance versus
Joe C car and Allen [inaudible].
Okay, so it's April 19th, 1961
does chief justice man please the court,
the supreme court is
hearing Baker versus Carr.
Yes,
it is an individual voting rights case
run by 11 qualified voters in the state
of Tennessee.
Now on the surface,
Baker versus Carr was about districts
and how people are counted in this
country.
And this is one of the most basic ways
that political power gets assigned in
America. Yeah. Like you know,
as populations grow in size,
that growth should be reflected
in the number of Congress people
that are representing
them. But at that time
in Tennessee, Tennessee hadn't
changed its legislative district.
The last reapportion
months, one in 19 and one
since 1901, which was
60 years earlier. Well,
this created big problems for urban areas
like Memphis because in those 60 years
people had moved to the cities in droves
and rural areas were getting smaller,
but the Tennessee state legislature
had refused to update its count. Right.
And it was still giving more
representation to those rural areas
in Tennessee. Um, the
figure was 23 to one,
NYU law professor Sam is that girl.
For people that don't understand that,
how does it actually dilute your vote?
Well, I mean, this is very simple.
You have one district that has, uh,
one person in it and you have another
district that has 23 people in it.
The district that has one person gives
all the power to that one person,
the district that has 23 people, uh,
spreads it out over all 23. Wait, what?
All right, think of it
this way. At that time,
a person in the city in Tennessee had
one 23rd as much of a voice in the
legislature as a person
living in the countryside.
And heres sort of the
insidious underbelly of that,
it just so happened that the people
living in the countryside are mostly white
and a large percentage of the people
living in the city were black.
Underlying all of the reapportionment
litigation, at least in the south,
was white supremacy.
That's Doug Smith
historian and the author
of on Democracy's doorstep.
This was deeply tied to white supremacy
and the maintenance of Jim Crow.
It was a method of making sure that rural
white legislatures continue to control
the power structure.
So you had this situation,
he says were a small minority
was choking the majority,
choking the the cities and the growing
suburban areas from any source,
any sorts of funds.
The cities couldn't get the money
they needed for roads, education,
social services. So the question
at the supreme court was,
and they would actually tackle
this in two separate hearings,
what should they do about this,
Aaron, you have your back
and here's where you get to
the ideological smackdown
liberals on the court,
like Douglas basically agreed
with the plaintiff when they are,
I say there's nothing in
the congregational United
States of America that are
nothing in the constitution of Tennessee.
That state government must remain an
agricultural commodity and there's nothing
good either one of those constitution
that said it takes 20 city residents to
equal one farm.
Liberals were like, yeah,
this is clearly an injustice.
People in the cities are getting screwed.
Their voting rights have been alluded and
debates to the point of nullification.
Well, the conservatives
are like, yes, people are
getting hurt, but we're not going to do
anything about it. We can't. Frankfurter
may affect the does a rotten rejoice
in doesn't mean a call today.
Most specifically said we cannot
get involved at as bad. This is,
there was not an issue that the court
should get involved in. Why now?
I do have to think of the
road that I'm going on.
What kind of role you're inviting me.
He was like, think of
where this will lead.
Considering the fact that this is
unique and if the situate isn't a unique
Tennessee situation.
If we end up doing this in Tennessee,
pretty soon we'll be intervening
in California, South Carolina.
Pretty soon we'll be rewriting
the entire U s legislative map.
Have to think of a lot of states,
and this is just fantasy for me.
This is the United States, not Tennessee.
Yeah, so basically he felt like this
would force the courts to get involved in
politics and he really believed that the
courts should never ever get involved
in politics. This is a,
this is an idea that goes way back
to something called the [inaudible]
political question doctrine. Political
question doctrine. Political question.
Doctrine says no federal court
can decide this issue at all.
The courts simply had no business
getting into what were considered to be
fundamentally political questions and
what could be more fundamentally political
than the makeup of a legislature.
It's a philosophy rooted in the notion
that unelected lifetime judges should not
be substituting their will for the will
of the people's elected representatives.
Frederick felt like even if you
have a terrible political situation,
if the justice has stepped in
and overruled the legislature,
that would be worse than doing nothing
at all because it would be fundamentally
undemocratic. He viewed,
he viewed the political question doctrine
is a crucial limitation on the federal
judicial power and he wasn't alone.
The courts had followed this guideline
for about 150 years and even with the
current case in Tennessee,
the federal court that first heard
the case recognized the situation and
actually referred to it as an [inaudible].
The evil is a serious one,
but should be corrected
without further delay in quote.
All right. You said that this is
a, this is a political question.
Malapportionment is a political question
and only the political branches can
handle this, right?
Of course they have no
power to do anything about
protecting and enforcing the
voting rights of these plaintiffs.
So
Belize the myth, man, that's cool.
When the lawyer for
Tennessee got up there,
I am not here defending the legislature.
He didn't try to defend how Tennessee was
counting or not counting. It's people.
He basically said, yeah,
what we're doing is bad,
but it's nobody's job but ours to fix.
Is it worth for the
legislature of Tennessee not
to reapportion or is it worse?
Well, the Federal District Gourds,
finally the age old doc separating,
he basically said, if you step in,
you're going to screw up the
balance of power in America.
The power in America comes from
we, the people, not the courts.
So this matter should be left up to the
people of Tennessee and their elected
representatives. Wait a
second. If the whole problem
is that you don't have a
voice in the legislature,
then how can you suddenly just have
a voice in the legislature? I mean,
the only way to change it would be if
the legislature itself were to give up
power and why would they
do that? Because of course,
once elected officials are in power,
they have a vested interest in keeping
their districts exactly as they are
because those were the districts
that elected them. And fundamentally,
electoral representatives knew
that if they redrew the lines,
that they would be, um,
voting themselves out of political power
that Ski Charles Professor Duke Law
School. So they had an incentive
not to do anything about this.
So for the liberals on the court,
they felt like this was a fundamental
flaw in our democracy that needed to be
fixed and nobody was going to fix it if
they didn't fix it. But for Frankfurter,
he's like, if you fix this one,
you're gonna have to fix it.
That one and that one and that one and
that one. And where's it going to stop?
If you do this, there is no way out.
[inaudible]
the court's going to get stuck
in what he called [inaudible]
political thicken. Ah,
the political thicken of the court
must not enter the political thicket.
That sounds like frankfurter.
He must've written those words.
And the imagery at the
thicket is that, uh, you know,
the deer very proudly with his
new horns goes into the thicket,
gets entangled and can never get out.
Frank for years, claim was
once the courts are in,
there will be nothing beyond
it and someday the courts
will be forced to declare
winners and losers of very
high profile elections.
[inaudible]
okay. So after the oral arguments
are over in Baker vs Carr,
that justice is headed to conference.
That's a meeting with just the nine
and when they went into the conference,
basically the court would divided right
down the middle and Charles Whittaker,
he was a potential swing
vote. Whitaker was deeply torn
[inaudible]
he'd been leaning Frankfurter's way, but
if there is a clear constitutional
right that's being violated
during those first, that first argument,
he asked a number of questions
that suggested a great
deal of sympathy with the
plaintiff.
Sam Is there not
power and duty in the court to
enforce that constitutional rights?
There was a lot of thought that he
might actually come down on the side of,
of the plaintiffs in that case. And I
think that's where frankfurter really,
really began to to rip into him
Justice Frankfurter right after the first
oral argument during the conference,
even 90 minutes speech, so talked
for 90 plus straight minutes,
darting around the room,
pulling books off the shelves,
holding books off the shelf,
reading from prior cases,
just sticky collating wildly to make
his point and the whole time looking
directly at Whitaker.
There was one account that I heard where
frankfurter went on for four hours,
four hours really lecturing Whitaker
really, really belittling him.
This guy, yes it was. It
was horribly intimidating.
At one point, one of the justices on
the liberal side, Justice Hugo black,
he took Whitaker aside.
Black was trying to make him feel
better and black said to Charles,
weird occurred. Just remember,
we're all boys grown tall.
We're not the gods who sit
on high and dispense justice,
but it's very difficult not
to see yourself in that role,
particularly if your vote might be
the vote that decides everything.
This started to weigh
heavily on Whitaker's mind.
[inaudible].
He was disturbed by the,
by having the way to the
supreme court on his shoulders.
[inaudible]
according to his family, Kate and Ken,
my mother tells me that he at that time
was under a lot of stress and spoke as
though he were dictating,
spoke his punctuation.
Hello Judith Comma, it's very
nice to meet you, period.
Clearly thinking about everything
that he might say being recorded.
I remember his stating that it felt
like all the words that he uttered were
being jeweled in stone as a result
of which he said you don't talk much.
[inaudible]
so after they heard the case the first
time [inaudible] couldn't make up his
mind. And actually incidentally
there was another justice
justice Stewart who was the other swing
vote in the case who also couldn't make
up his mind.
Okay.
The court decided to hear the case again
in the fall just because they needed
more time
and over the summer, interesting.
Halfway to Chris said he remained deeply
divided that he'd actually written
memos on both sides of the
issue. Doug Smith says,
Whittaker wrote both an opinion for
intervening and bigger versus car and a
descent against intervening and bigger
versus car at the same time.
Meanwhile, as he's doing this,
justice frankfurters circulates a 60
page memo explaining how this was a
political question that should
not be decided by the courts.
Scott, you know a fire in his
belly. He's not gonna let this one
number six, Charles Deputy
Baker, that was tell him
Monday, October 9th,
1961 it's 10:00 AM and
the court is back again.
Does that change justice and please,
hello, you're arguing the case against
the Tennessee legislature begins,
Tennessee voters seek
federal court protection.
Frankfurter sits quietly for
about five minutes listening
without the light,
and then you don't mean to him
because if you start to go wrong,
you start to look the same time I
add no right for the fifth time,
I did not miss the justice right ratio.
You gave a minute. My child's again,
termination of the state. I wasn't
trying to deal with that. The problem
doesn't include any state. It's
different when you and much more, well,
it's passed on it by denying or right
under it. If that isn't passing on it.
I don't know. Why does pappy, of
course not. Mr. Justice Frankfurter
Frankfurter hammers the attorney's with
questions during the course of oral
arguments.
He speaks approximately 170 times 170 170.
Damn Charles Whittaker.
You have some system for the allocation
of its legislate doors to districts or
county
17 times.
Well, uh, essentially
after nearly four hours of oral arguments,
the race has now
the justice is recess
and go into conference.
Frankfurter needed desperately.
He had a good Winokur and he would kept
after him like a dog after a bone trying
to persuade them and that harassing
he got, I have to make a point here.
It was a nightmare and
I saw the nightmare.
How so? Describe it to me. Well, he was
okay.
A nervous wreck and like a cat
on a hot tin roof. I found out,
I don't know if he told me or his wife
told me he was on tranquilizers to try to
overcome what he thought was
just work related stress. Well,
clearly something was taking hold of
him who had trouble concentrating.
Highly fraught.
I would characterize his eventual
breakdown as something of a slow descent
[inaudible]
by the early spring after the court
had returned from its winter recess,
a Whitaker was absent from the court.
You mean like he just didn't, he like
didn't show for work one day apparently.
So it's clerks didn't
know where he was. Um,
the other justices didn't
know his whereabouts.
He just disappeared really in the middle
of what's going to become one of the,
you know, monumental decisions of
the 20th century. He disappears.
He had to escape. Where did he go? Well,
he went to really what would be a cabin
in the woods in the middle of Wisconsin
and he,
he called up one of his former
law associates in Kansas
City to come up and join
him.
And according to Craig Smith, he
in this guy whose name was Sam ob,
they would just sit there
on the bank of the lake
in silence.
[inaudible]
they would sit for hours on
end, not talking to each other,
just waiting for the justice to speak.
No cause for pride and
what has happened. And so,
you know, we have no way of knowing
what he was thinking at that moment.
But I imagine
he was just sitting there and he was
thinking about these two realities that
could unfold. Like on the one hand,
if the court stepped into politics,
they could protect him.
[inaudible]
but on the other hand, it's gonna
precedent with this set. It's a sad deal.
Mr President, when we weekend, would
it make the court too powerful?
Marsha Richard, shiny versus Albert Gore,
in which case your Bush protect the
people as received president of the United
States 200 and images. Mine went
back and forth, back and forth. Yeah.
Well, and when Whitaker decided that
he really had to get back to work,
then this protege would say to him, no,
just relax dude. Just
take it easy. And, um,
get yourself together before
you decide to go back.
After three weeks, justice
Whitaker returns to DC
back to Washington, uh, for a few days.
That's Ken Tigan, his son. [inaudible]
well, you found my father
to be really in Extremis,
uh, a debate and, and I
think a borderline suicidal.
When you said he was
suicidal, what do you mean
there?
There was an instance in which my brother
found my father going upstairs to get
a shotgun.
Yeah.
A few days later, Charles Woodpecker
checks himself into a hospital.
There is some evidence that it was really
justice Douglas who convinced Whitaker
to go to the hospital.
I do recall that. I have
a nervous breakdown.
That's justice William Douglas again.
Yeah.
He was at Walter Reed Hospital
and I've been up to see him
that she had been up to see him.
[inaudible]
he wasn't very current physical
condition. Very worried and
depressed. Yes. I thought he should do.
I told him I didn't think that he was
being in a position to decide what he
should do until they get well.
A few weeks later,
March 29 1962 the presidential press
conference from the new State Department
Auditorium, Washington d c
several announcements to make.
It is with extreme regret that I announced
the retirement of associate justice
of the Supreme Court, Charles Evans,
Whitaker effective April
1st justice Whitaker.
I remember the Supreme Court for nearly
five years and of the federal judiciary.
Vanilli eight years is retiring at the
written direction of his position or
reasons of disability.
I know that the bench and the bar of the
entire nation join me in commending Mr.
Justice Whitaker for his devoted service
to his country during a critical period
in it's history. Next,
I want to take this opportunity to stress
again the importance of the tax bill
now before the House of Representatives.
Wow. Just being made and whatever happened
with the case with they can record.
Well, Whitaker didn't
vote on bigger versus car,
so you could say that this case
that essentially broke him,
his vote didn't count. Wow. Not around
the time that he was in the hospital,
there was sort of this liberal coup at
the court where Frankfurter lost a couple
of other votes. So in the
end, the decision actually
wasn't very close at all.
What was it? It was six
to ah, Frankie. Yeah.
And Brennan wrote the majority opinion
and he says that this whole kind of
cluster that we've been fighting over
of how states and Tennessee count their
voters, that this is something
the courts can and should look at.
So in other words, they decided to lower
their Ahrens and go into the thicket.
Oh, Yay. They did. No. Yay. Um, and
just one or two final questions. Um,
what happened to Justice Frankfurter?
Well, the,
the thing that I find perhaps
most extraordinary is it
less than two weeks after
the decision in Baker vs Carr came down,
Felix Frankfurter was working at his
desk at the Supreme Court and Frankfurter
Secretary found him sprawled on the
floor of his office from a stroke.
He suffered a massive stroke and
then never returned to service.
And while he was in the
hospitals, solicitor general,
Archibald Cox visited
Frankfurter. And Frankfurter. He,
he was in a wheelchair
and could barely speak,
but he apparently conveyed to Archibald
Cox that the decision maker versus car
had essentially caused his stroke.
He felt so passionately that the court
should stay out of the case that he
physically physically deteriorated
after the court had gone the other way.
[inaudible]
after Baker versus Carr,
President Kennedy essentially had two
Supreme Court vacancies to fill now
Whitaker seat.
He filled with a guy who turned out to
be a moderate Frankfurter's vacancy.
That second vacancy.
It's that vacancy that will lead to
the appointment of a man named Arthur
Goldberg.
That is the fifth vote that the four
liberals would are regarded as the four
liberals.
That becomes the fifth vote that they
need really to create what has come to be
regarded as the Warren court revolution.
[inaudible]
this is when the supreme court basically
became an agent for social change.
That revolution that
begins with the 1962 term.
That's the revolution that is going to
change this dark tower that at one man,
one vote, the way we withdraw
our political boundaries.
Then the prosecutor withheld and fashion
the way we think of criminal justice
[inaudible] small black armband,
the way we treat first amendment,
religious education, religious
and obscenity issues.
That's the war in court
that people remember.
And that's the court that came into
existence with Felix Frankfurter left.
And so just thinking about that question
that that woman asked all the way at
the beginning of the
story. Yes. Could you, um,
address what I see is the increasing
politicization of the court,
the apotheosis of which I
guess was, uh, you know,
voting or electing Bush
to be our president.
You can kind of draw a line from this
moment in Baker vs Carr all the way to
December 9th, 2000
block here on the east. The polls
in six new states have just closed.
And the lead story at this hour is the
state of Florida is too close to call.
I think fields from, for to with
us said C. And what we found was,
and that's what I told you,
that's what would happen,
is that eventually you will, you
will be deciding a partisan question,
which presidential candidate essentially
received the most votes for those who
felt themselves on the
losing side of pushy core.
This was just this Frankfurter's revenge.
This was the moment that a
Baker v Carr had opened up.
And when I teach this to students, uh,
and particularly in the decade
after Bush v Gore, when, uh, the,
the, the center sent to Ben Sentiments
about this were still quite,
I would say to them, well, is
this was frankfurter, right?
And I remember a student, uh, in
the mid two thousands who said, uh,
in class, I never
thought I would say this,
but because I hated the
outcome and Bush Free Gore,
I was so angry when the court interceded.
But if push Sri Gores the price
we have to pay for the courts,
making the overall political system
work somewhat more tolerably properly.
It's a price I'm willing to pay.
Oh,
before we totally sign off
what happened to Douglas,
we sort of lost track of him. So
after Baker versus Carr was decided,
he went on to be a supreme court justice
for 13 more years. And to this day,
he actually holds the record for being
the longest serving justice of all time,
36 years. And Frankfurter.
So Baker vs Carr was the
last case that he ever heard,
and he died a few years afterwards
and, and, and Charles would accrue.
Did he ever recover? Well, after
Whitaker retired from the court,
he moved back to Kansas
City with his family.